In preparation for his upcoming glasses expo, Grant needs to figure out how to
ship all of his wipers and the glasses that they're being modeled on.
Unfortunately, he's not going to have the nozzles ready in time but his
investors are still confident that they'll be plenty of excitement about the
wipers on their own. Grant's just worried about how to get the wipers to the
expo. He's planning on bringing all of his model glasses wipers to the expo in a
suitcase, but his concern is that the suitcase will be overweight. When his
suitcase is empty it weighs 7 pounds, and each glasses wiper set, along with its
protective packaging, only weighs 1 half a pound, or 0.5 pounds.
Can you find a relationship between the number of glasses wiper sets that Grant
packs and the total weight of his suitcase? Please use x for the number of wiper
sets and y for the total weight.